the president was hardly visible as he
departed for his weekend retreat at camp
david he left it to his spokesperson in
a statement to reiterate that he does
not regret his decision an orderly
drawdown is the phrase the
administration is sticking with
and yet on the ground in afghanistan the
white flag of the taliban and images
which show that every assumption made by
the americans was wrong from all corners
of the country videos emerging which
show the scale and speed of the taliban
advance this is kandahar in the south
support here for the taliban is
strongest and on a u.s military vehicle
they celebrated at a base in herat in
the far west fighters seized afghan
military equipment
and in logar province just south of the
capital the taliban released a whole
jail of prisoners
this isn't this isn't orderly it's kind
of hard to believe there can't be any
regret but there's no way i don't think
he can ever express that
i think president biden was elected into
office in part
to begin to withdraw from the so-called
forever wars and just listen to the
president a month ago is a taliban
takeover of afghanistan now inevitable
no
it is not it's taken just four weeks for
that statement to be proved so
spectacularly and alarmingly wrong it
was donald trump's policy to pull the
troops out joe biden adopted the
commitment believing it would play well
with voters here but the reality
thousands of miles away is now on him
the president and his advisers had
gambled that the taliban would stick to
commitments not to let al qaeda and
other terror groups return already
that's looking like wishful thinking
doug london is a former cia operations
officer and the u.s counterterrorism
chief covering afghanistan the taliban
and al-qaeda he says are literally
intermarried well i would not be
surprised to see
al-qaeda members moving back to
afghanistan from iran where many of them
sought refuge in sanctuary from
counter-terrorism pressure from the
united states the uk and others
and
basically taking advantage of the
opportunities to get back into the
business of training plotting and
planning and using the facilities of
afghanistan to project power outward
under the calmness of the kabul skyline
the fear and sense of betrayal cannot be
overstated the displacement camps are
filling and the 3 000 u.s troops who
will arrive here by the end of the
weekend cannot help their mission is
only to protect u.s civilians as that
orderly withdrawal is completed mark
stone sky news in washington